welcome to Hillsdale colleges campus
here in Washington DC this is the Allen
P Kirby Center for Constitutional
studies and citizenship I am Matthew
Spalding I run hills dales operations
back here in Washington DC I'm also the
Dean of our soon-to-be opening Graduate
School of Government
here in Washington see so you can watch
for that we have a great topic this
evening and a great and dear friend
speaking to us that I'm happy to have
join us our topic is growth both
timeless and timely as it turns out it's
timely because how we understand
ourselves our history and our continuing
purpose is at the heart of what makes us
a nation now the American story is
taught in our schools is crucial to how
citizens are formed and thus to the
future of our country and it's great
story right now our schools don't seem
to be doing a good job at that
indeed many are quite hostile to the
American story itself this debate about
America its past and whether we should
be patriotic towards it is now engaged
in a public debate not that it has been
engaged before but it seems to be a
little bit more direct and partisan and
intense shall we say America's past in
public defense of it is a stuff it turns
out of hatred and racism in white
supremacy yet I don't hear much in that
public debate that doesn't go back to
the deeper problem of what the leading
scholars and textbooks have been
teaching our students but the last thing
we need like we all agree is another
history book
I'm sorry to say but we what we do need
and what we long needed is a clear and
compelling narrative of the great
American story an honest account that is
also compelling and inspiring for
students but for us too and I think we
have one bill McClay is an American
historian he's an award-winning author
and teacher he's received his BA from
st. John's College and his PhD in
history from Johns Hopkins he currently
serves as the GT and Libby Blankenship
chair in history of Liberty at the
University of Oklahoma he's held
numerous positions around here and
elsewhere the Woodrow Wilson Center
international center for scholars he was
a senior senior fellow at the Trinity
forum and a senior fellow at the ethics
and Public Policy Center he's the author
of many books including why place
matters geography identify identity and
civic life in the modern America a
student's guide to US history and the
masterless self and society and American
in moderate America which won the the
Kirti award of the organization of
American Historians for the best book in
American intellectual history he has
also recently penned a new introduction
to an edition of Russell Kirk's concise
concise guide to conservatism and now
his written land of hope an invitation
to the great American story just
published by our good friends at
encounter books and this fall I'm happy
to announce Bill will be teaching an
online course centered around the block
for Hillsdale College
but it shouldn't prevent you from buying
the book because there's all students
know to do well in class you need to buy
the book please join me in welcoming
good friend bill McClay
Thank You Man and by the way everything
I know about George Washington I know
from Matt Spaulding so you can for
whatever it's worth well it's wonderful
to be here and I have to say at the
outset that I have a phalanx of my
former students here in the front row
who are going to be scrutinizing every
word I say and so I feel very much as if
I better be on my game okay this this is
a textbook that we're talking about here
and and many people have asked me why on
earth did you do this why did you write
a textbook and it's of course the
assumption is that I'm going to make
lots of money well we'll see about that
but that given the fact that I was I'm
going against the grain of a great deal
of academic publishing textbook
publishing pedagogical practice and so
on that's not really my expectation but
I wanted to write a book that was
directed at young people of young people
of all ages but and actually I've been
astonished and how well the book has
done in the trade market because
actually we've only begun trying to sell
it to schools so I hope that's that's a
good augury
but I wrote it with young people in mind
with the kind of account that I would
want for myself for my children for
other people's children not as the
be-all and end-all not as a
comprehensive narrative I didn't mean it
as my version of the Aeneid for America
or anything like that it is it is more
modestly as the subtitle says an
invitation and and not something that's
meant to be definitive or pretends to be
definitive but it is a story
it is an account of American history
that is rendered in narrative form that
tries I'll read you some passages before
this is all done to give you a feel for
what I tried to do stylistically another
reason why I did it is that Matt
mentioned when he introduced me that I
had written something called the
students guide to US history
probably 15 years ago or so and 4i aside
books and it's part of a wonderful
series that they they do on the
disciplines student guides to various
disciplines and some of the people
carving Mansfield on political theory I
mean you can't beat that
John Lukacs the late John Lukacs on
history historiography and in various
others and so they're really good they
did kind of you know have to scrape down
to get me for doing US history but but
it's actually been a pretty steady
seller for them and there was a period
of time which I hardly a week went by
that I didn't get a message from
somebody saying I love your student
guide but you don't recommend a textbook
why is that and you know what getting
fifty hundred of these over a period of
time I began to think you know maybe
they have a point and I always wrote
back the same thing I didn't recommend a
textbook because I didn't think there
was one I could recommend I said I kind
of like Paul Johnson's book through the
American people but it has some some
problems in some asymmetries and you
know it isn't the be-all and end-all
either so I had this thought in the back
of my mind that at some point you need
to stop complaining and do something and
contribute something I've written a lot
of articles complaining about the
absence of synthesis in American
historiography the fragmentation of the
field and at some point you just have to
put up or shut up and try to do
something more integrative more
synthetic more holistic to bring some
kind of order out of the chaos so all of
these things were in the back of my mind
when Rodger Kimball approached me about
this this wasn't something I initiated
entirely on my own it's something I'd
been thinking about and Rodger Kimball
who's the publisher of encounter books
approached me about it and he managed to
catch me at a weak moment it was a
Sunday afternoon
Rodger does business on Sunday he's the
only person I know who does that he
called me on the phone and I was in a
very mellow mood you know I was feeling
very Sabbath oriented and kind of kindly
disposed to the entire human race and
and satisfied with myself you know after
repenting a whole lot earlier in the day
and he said he talked me into it I
agreed I have the phone told my wife I
agreed to do this [ __ ] are you out of
your mind so so I went on with it and
and I started looking and more seriously
at the the other text books that were
out there and and I felt more and more
strongly the need I'll talk about this
more in a minute the need for something
else something different say a few words
about the textbook world and this this
is not definitive either but it's
basically dominated by the three big
publishers Pearson mcgraw-hill and the
Harcourt and their there are others
obviously but the lion's share the
market is dominated by them and that
chilling dominance is likely to continue
there's also I think a great deal of
influence sway over the over the
teaching of history exerted by authors
like Howard Zinn whose people's history
the United States has sold I think over
2 million copies and is I
I to be fair and I here I quote Michael
Kaizen the the historian of American
social movements a man of the left that
kayson's account of American history is
a comic book and it's a sort of a
reductive simplistic version of American
history in which the good guys all wear
white hats and are generally oppressed
and the bad guys wear black hats and
generally hold positions of authority
not not you know the most full and
complete guide to American history so
but Howard Zinn tells a good story I
think any of you who've ever read Xin
he's actually a very good writer and
sometimes writing fairy tales can be
more more rewarding in in terms of the
prose then trying to render a
complicated morally tangled account
which is what our history is anyway I
what I wanted to mention and this just
came up this is breaking news yesterday
I read in one of the education online
publications inside higher education
that Pearson has decided to go all
digital with their textbooks fifteen
hundred titles which presumably will
include their history titles and they
will be you know completely they won't
be complete you can get the print
edition on demand but clearly that over
time will fade out because of the
expense and because of the fact the
digital version will be updated
constantly and so students will be
required to in institutions will be
required to offer the latest version
latest and greatest version of these
constantly updated texts so the pearsons
actually been fairly honest about what
they're trying to do they're really
trying to drive the secondary bookmark
out of business eBay and and various
others resellers of books and even the
rental book market which is very strong
in higher education now they say what
they want to promote is a greater degree
of interactivity with students
pedagogical progress but I think it's
very clear that in the long run and the
long run may not be too far off
institutions that adopt Pearson books
will be required to to restrict their
students access to only things that are
on the Pearson platform so the books
will cease to be a factor and the words
will be written on sort of the
equivalent of digital sand constantly
subject to revision and then revision
after that and then revision after that
it's a sort of Orwellian
prospect back in the early years of
printing printers had a saying that they
would often mount in their in their
print shop so
litora scripts of MANET which means in
Latin the the written word remains which
i think is actually a beautiful
beautiful saying but when a civilization
such as ours which has been defined by
books you know we are Christians and
Jews are the people of the book we now
will be people of the screen people who
are tied to the ever changing ever fluid
presentation of the past and other
subject areas of their discipline areas
by by the nature of digital technology
so this is part of the environment into
which land of hope came comes and I'm
definitely swimming against the tide
encounter is swimming against the tide
where we want wanted to produce
something of enduring value something
that has a quality of permanence about
it that you know it's been a long time
since I've heard anyone speak of
textbooks being venerable they so that
may be too much to shoot for that that
will be something that readers will
decide whether they venerate it or not
but that's what we were shooting for I
want to say a few things about encounter
because a number of people were because
I had people who are really surprised
and amazed that I wanted to do this in
the first place and then when I told
them that I wanted to do it that I was
doing with encounter they were they were
even a mildly appalled and said what
they're not a textbook publisher there
you know and there there's all kinds of
problems and what I found was in fact
and I this is not a proposition that one
could confirm empirically but I don't
think I could have written the book any
other way with any other publisher
encounter did not subject me to the
vetting of textbook committees in key
states Texas California they the vetting
of interest groups of pressure groups of
stakeholders as we like to call them no
I was all by myself in my study writing
this thing I didn't have any research
assistants I basically didn't even talk
to anybody my students will confirm I
never talked about this I was I was
going doing this in secret
little mole in the night and I did it
all by myself I wrote every word it
reflects my outlook Roger
Kimball and the people it encountered I
would say it actually bothered me at
times that they didn't interfere at all
I'm so used to editors you know kind of
looking over my shoulder and saying well
you know you don't want to say that and
or
suggesting even more strongly that the
perspective I've taken is not quite what
we want and this might have set some
people or whatever never never once did
they interject themselves and and and
and they didn't the editing process was
fairly light I would I wouldn't have
minded it being a little more
heavy-handed there are places where I
cringe a little bit now reading it but
but but on the whole it was a very
respectful edit so this was something
that didn't go through the meat grinder
or the food processor that most text
books go through and I'm very grateful
to Roger Kimble into his staff for
giving me this freedom and and I think
the book is better as a result of that
it does it does reflect for better or
worse the perspective of an author
rather than being something assembled if
in effect by committee
and by a rather disheveled committee at
that I'm actually convinced that many
textbooks are not read by anyone and I
mean the people in the publishing houses
don't read it the the authors the big
name historians who were on the the
cover I don't think they've read the
things that are being published in their
name I'm not sure who was reading them
but but but the the biggest surprise I
had in this whole process and and and I
there's about 25 text books piled up in
my study at home
was that the real the the the problem
was less with ideological imbalance
there is that especially when you get
into the period after the night after
1960 or so but the real problem is these
these books are unreadable and it's no
reason no wonder to me that young people
don't want to read them I don't want to
read them and they it's it's a disgrace
these books often cost
fifty dollars or more and they they
appear not to have been edited for
reading comprehension let alone you know
fact-checking so I may be getting a
little carried away here but but but it
really is very bad and one of the things
I was worried about and some of my
colleagues on the university level
looked at chapters and I said well you
know this is all you've got everything
right here but you know this is reading
levels way too high for high school
students well I also tested the same
chapters out on my former students or
our high school teachers and they all
said oh this is fine this is much better
than what we've been giving them text
books by X Y & Z so we in some ways we
underestimate the capacity of our young
people to read books
if interesting books are put in front of
them if books that can grab them and
compel them that have a narrative thrust
to them that that fire their imagination
that that that conveyed to him to them
that history is not just an inert
recitation of facts but it's a it's a
moral enterprise it's a task of
reflection it's uh but it's a part of
what it means to be human to think about
the past to think about the stories of
the past okay
let me just talk a little bit about the
book in terms of some of the some of the
emphases that I bring to it and these
are things that run through the book as
a whole I like to think is like to think
in musical terms that it's sort of like
a Rondo you know it's a multiple Rondo
there are several Rondo themes maybe
about five of them that keep popping up
and recurring through the text sort of a
fugle Rondo
if there is such a thing and well and
and most of these themes are encompassed
in the title itself Land of Hope and
invitation to the great American story
which is the one element of the book
where I did have a lot of wrestling with
the the publisher because they they you
know publishers want certain words
certain phrases that are going to help
them sell the book and I bought them on
on that I think I think I'm pretty much
won I got the title I wanted so let me
just break it down first there it's a
Land of Hope land that that's certainly
an element in my outlook on American
history the America is not just an idea
America is a concrete entity a nation a
nation that has a history a very
particular history and that if we're to
understand is it's not enough to sort of
understand certain principles as
important as that is we have to
understand how those principles became
instantiated or not instantiated as the
case may be how their worked through and
worked out how they're developed how
they they they they come to be dominant
at least we hope in in in our national
life and maybe to to dominant in some
cases so I America's definitely about
ideas and but in America is not simply
an idea America is a land a land with a
venerable history with I think
particularly of those who are at
Arlington National Cemetery and and
graveyards of those who've given their
lives for the country the history of
sacrifices on behalf of the country
these are things that bind us to it in
ways that go beyond
questions of ideas or principles their
particularity z' and not abstractions
that's maybe another way to put it
so ii hope land of hope and several
people said why is it lame why is it not
Land of Hope and Glory you know the
angular file types and then people so
always gonna be a lot about Obama in
this book this is actually very little
about things after 1992 which I will
explain in a minute but part of what I
meant to do by emphasizing hope is it's
complicated and I think you see the
working out of the complexity over the
course of the book is that that
fundamentally hope is it's a spiritual
attribute it's an attribute it's a it's
a quality of soul something that's not
explicable and strictly material terms
but it is a characteristic of a kind of
the country that we seek to rise above
or transcend or move beyond that which
is given that that what's get our given
state in life is not the final word
about it and and so that we have that
sort of striving aspect which I argue
goes back to the very beginnings in fact
this is a little bit fanciful but then
in the first chapter I even talked about
the the the the fact that the Western
Hemisphere so far as we know has no
truly native peoples in it that that so
far as we know twenty thirty forty
thousand years ago the first migrants to
the Western Hemisphere came over the
Bering Strait and and through filtered
down to people the continent and and
then we have they from the other
direction
the Erickson's and other explorers
coming from Europe and that there's a
long tradition in European myth if you
will literature of a of a a mystic land
in the East a place of renewal the
Elysian Fields Atlanta so on it's a it's
a very well established control within
European thought an anticipation of
America before the fact there too you
have a notion of hope hope is the
prospect of redemption the prospect of
starting the world over again starting
life over again a new Zion and errand
into the wilderness the language of New
England Puritanism so I think all of
this and then it that becomes
transmogrified into more secular
understandings of hope but still it's
it's it's an elemental part of the
makeup of the soul of America story
invitation the great American story and
that emphasis on story is something that
I insist on right from the start that
narratives are an essential part of the
way that we human beings make sense of
the world we live our lives suspended in
their it is often that we don't
completely understand these webs of
signification that upholds us that that
define the way we see the world the way
we aspire in the world so and in fact
let me read you I'm gonna read some more
things but I have a little discussion of
this right early on in the book so this
is the right moment to read it the
impulse to write this is on page X I for
those of you who have the book the first
page of the introduction yes I it's 11
for you landlubbers yes
about five four or five lines up from
the bottom the impulse to write history
and organize our world around stories is
intrinsic to us as human beings we are
at our core remembering and story making
creatures and stories are one of the
chief ways we find meaning in the flow
of events what we call history and
literature are merely the refinement and
intensification of that basic human
impulse that need and then I go on to
say the word need is not an exaggeration
for the human animal meaning is not a
luxury it is a necessity without it we
perish historical consciousness is to
civilize Society but memory is to
individual identity that's a phrase
worth pausing over but without memory
without the stories by which our
memories are carried forward we cannot
say who or what we are without them our
life and thought dissolve into a
meaningless unrelated rush of events
without them we cannot do the most human
of things we cannot learn use language
pass on knowledge raise children
establish rules of conduct engage in
science or dwell harmoniously in society
without them we cannot govern ourselves
nor can we have a sense of the future as
a time we know will come because we
remember that other tomorrow's have come
and gone this next sentence I think
applies to some of what I see around me
today a culture without memory will
necessarily be barbarous and easily
tyrannize even if it's technologically
advanced the incessant waves of daily
events will occupy all our attention and
defeat our efforts to connect past
present and future thereby diverting us
from an understanding of the human
things that unfold in time including the
paths of our own lives forgive me I just
one little bit more here the stakes were
beautifully expressed in the words of
the great Jewish writer Isaac Bashevis
singer
when a day passes it is no longer there
what remains of it nothing more than a
story if stories weren't told or books
weren't written man would live like the
beasts only for the day the whole world
all human life is one long story oh I
can't stop there singer was right singer
was right as individuals as communities
as countries we are nothing more than
flotsam and jetsam without the stories
in which we find our lives meaning there
are stories of which we are already a
part whether we know it or not there the
basis of our common life the webs of
meaning and which are shared identities
are suspended ok they're all stopped so
I'm very interested in this book in sort
of cultivating story the the reflective
attitude towards the path mediated
through story and story is a way that we
remember that we that we stay in touch
with the past that the past becomes
present to us and the president becomes
informed by the past its and their
stories and their stories of course
Andre Malraux
the great French writer and resistance
figure somewhere I've never been able
find where he said this but somewhere he
says what is a man a miserable pile of
secrets and I well that's one way of
thinking about a biography all right and
there there are biographies and
biographers out there who seem to swear
by that understanding that a person is a
what a person really is is what he or
she hides what they don't disclose what
they attempt to pass off in another way
but I think that there's another way to
think about
biography there's another way to think
about history and and instead of
thinking of it in this negative way as a
compilation of secrets of things that
are missing and that is to give I think
credence to the mythic dimension to the
aspirational dimension of history and
that's one of the things I try to do in
the book without blinking the fact that
we've often done terrible things that we
have not been a land of hope for
everyone and that hope is as I
repeatedly say in the book a
double-edged quality because to be to be
a land of Hope is also to be a land of
disappointment a land of frustration a
land of disillusionment even and we
experience all these things we wouldn't
experience them if we weren't a land of
Hope if we didn't hew to that that
doctrine and finally invitation this is
an invitation the great American story
this is sort of a way of saying
communicating I'm not pretending that
this is the definitive American history
that that has every answer to every
question one of the things that was so
frustrating about writing this is that
you I kept coming across things I
couldn't go into without losing the
narrative thread you've got to throw
things out you've got to throw a lot out
and everybody who's ready to said you
know that was I really like this but why
didn't you say something about X and you
know I all I can say is you know I
thought about that it hurt when I had to
leave that out and does that satisfy you
at least at least I was in pain that I
didn't but it is it and I think of its
triage and the lifeboat you know you
have to throw you know your second best
friend out in order to keep the thing
from sinking so you have to make very
hard judgments but but it's also an
invitation in the sense that I do want
it to lead I wanted to catch people's
interest I want young people
particularly and all your young people
- - - want to go further to want to
supersede what I've done here and to
make American history the the the the
fascinating thing that it intrinsically
is but that we I think have deprived it
of that interest okay let me it there's
several passages I wanted to read and
then we'll stop and I'll take questions
but I just partly i want to give you a
sense of what i try to do with some
familiar maybe maybe familiar I hope
familiar parts of American history
before I do that I want to read words
that are not mine but the the the the
epigraph page there for those of you who
have the book it's alright this is there
were two things that I knew I wanted to
have in this book before I wrote
anything else one was the title at land
of hope the subtitle is what we fought
over but they let me have Land of Hope
and this epigraph by John Dos Passos who
was a great American novelist a great
American writer man of the of the
radical left in his youth who moved to
the sensible right let me read this it's
from an essay called the use of the past
it seems so relevant to me there's a bit
by it was written in 1941 and you know
it's a lot going on in 1941 but every
generation rewrites the past in easy
times history is more or less of an
ornamental art but in times of danger we
are driven to the written record by
pressing need to find answers to the
riddles of today we need to know what
kind of firm ground other men belonging
to generations before us have found to
stand on in spite of changing conditions
of life they were not very different
from ourselves their thoughts were the
grandfather's of our thoughts I love
that phrase their thoughts for the
grandfathers of our thoughts they
managed to meet situations as difficult
as those we have to face to meet them
sometimes lightheartedly and it's some
measure to make
their hopes prevail we need to know how
they did it in times of change in danger
when there's a quicksand of fear under
men's reasoning a sense of continuity
with generation has gone before can
stretched like a lifeline across the
scary present and get us past that idiot
delusion of the exceptional now that
blocks good thinking
that is why in times like ours when old
institutions are caving in and being
replaced by new institutions not
necessarily in accord with most men's
preconceived hopes political thought has
to look backwards as well as forwards
isn't that marvelous
I mean if so much here but one of the
things I want to emphasize this idiot
delusion of the exceptional now this is
one of the things I find in teaching
it's very hard to get younger people
interested in the past because they
think we're living in an unprecedented
time that and we in the times we live in
are so unprecedented the technologies
that we carry around in our pockets are
so transformative in their character
that there's really no point in and
looking at what went on in the 17th
century the 19th century that's all been
superseded and it's it's an ill-informed
I mean it's a it's a way of justifying
not learning anything about the things
you already don't know anything about
but but it is I think a real conviction
and it's something that that this
endless sort of parade of sensation and
media images and so on that in which
everything is always being succeeded by
something else nothing is permanent
nothing's enduring that feeds that and
reinforces that sense that we do live in
an exceptional now capital end now that
blocks good thinking
let me I'm going to skip I'm gonna skip
this one because I
here a lot of times people are
interested how do I handle some of the
really sticky difficult questions
it's a slavery Native American it's that
sort of thing and here's an example this
is the end of the chapter that deals
with the Constitutional Convention and
this will give you a sense of the kind
of reasoning I engage in at the time of
the Constitutional Convention the
institution of race-based slavery was
deeply enmeshed in one segment of the
national economy despite all the ways
it's very existence seemed to stand in
glaring contradiction to the national
commitment liberty equality and
self-rule there was real bite to the
mocking question fired at Americans in
1775 by the British writer Samuel
Johnson how is it that we hear the
loudest yelps for Liberty among the
drivers of Negroes close quote it was an
excellent question
particularly if one kept in mind how
many of the prominent founders including
Thomas Jefferson and George Washington
with themselves owners of slaves how we
wonder today could such otherwise
enlightened and exemplary individuals
have been so blind to the fundamental
humanity of those they confined how
could they have made their peace with
practices so utterly contradictory to
all they stood for there is no easy
answer to these questions but surely a
part of the answer is that each of us is
born into a world that we did not make
and there's only with the greatest
effort and often at very great cost that
we're ever able to change that world for
the better
moral sensibilities are not static they
develop and deepen over time and general
moral progress is very slow part of the
study of history involves a training of
the imagination learning to see
historical actors as speaking and acting
in their own times rather than ours and
learning to see even our heroes as an
all too human
texture of admirable and unanimity x'
people like us who may like us be
constrained by circumstances beyond
their control and then I conclude this
chapter saying let's see the lamb bivolo
this is regarding slavery built into the
structure of the Constitution we're
almost certainly unavoidable in the
short term in order to achieve an
effective political union of the nation
what we need to understand is how the
original compromise no longer became
acceptable to increasing numbers of
Americans especially in one part of the
Union and why slavery a ubiquitous
institution in human history came to be
seen not merely in as an unfortunate
evil but a sinful impediment to human
progress a stain upon an entire nation
we live today on the other side of a
great transformation and moral
sensibility a transformation that was
taking place but was not yet completed
in the very years the United States was
being formed there's more but two other
things this is this is a Lincoln and I
talked about the fact that Lincoln of
course had to run for re-election in the
middle of the Civil War and and and for
a very long time in 1864 he thought he
was certain to lose and I talked about
the reasons for that we let me just pick
it up here we forget or are unaware of
the depth and breadth of Lincoln's
unpopularity during his entire time in
office few great leaders have been more
comprehensively disdained or loathed or
underestimated
allô southern view of him of course was
the expected but it was widely shared
north of the mason-dixon line as the
lincoln biographer David Donald put it
Lincoln's own associates thought him
quote a simple susan apologies to any
Susan's out there that's it
Oh Susi's I know we're all complicated
but a simple susan a baboon a nameless
punster a smutty Joker he was in the
view of the abolitionist wendell
phillips a huckster in politics a
first-rate second-rate man George
McClellan openly disdained him as a
well-meaning baboon McClellan him being
his opponent in the 1864 election and
here's my comment on this we need to
remember this is generally how history
happens it is not like a Hollywood movie
in which the background music swells and
the crowd and the room applauds and
leaves to its feet as the orator
dispenses timeless words and the camera
pans the room full of smiling faces in
real history the background music does
not swell the trumpets do not sound and
the carping critics often seem louder
than the applause the leader or the
soldier has to wonder whether he's
acting in vain whether the criticisms
are of others are in fact true whether
time will judge him harshly whether his
sacrifice will count for anything
few great leaders have felt this burden
more completely than Lincoln and then
finally and I think this has something
to say about our current attitude
towards the past at least in some parts
of the population those who want to kind
of go out and and do a Robespierre you
know cleansing us of all remnants of the
past to which we find objectionable
today in the era of ultimate truths that
was ironic this is the end of the Civil
War on April 9th 1865 after last flurry
of feudal resistance Lee General Lee
robert e lee face facts and arranged to
meet grant ulysses s grant Union General
in chief and a brick home in the village
of Abu Maddux courthouse
jigna to surrender his army he could not
formally surrender the whole Confederacy
but the surrender of his army would
trigger the surrender of all others and
so it represented the end of the
Confederate cause it was a poignant
scene dignified and restrained and sad
as when a terrible storm that has raged
and blown has finally exhausted itself
leaving behind a strange and reverent
calm purged of all passion the two men
had known one another in the Mexican War
and had not seen one another in nearly
20 years Lee arrived first wearing his
elegant dress uniform soon to be joined
by Grant clad in blood spattered sac
coat his trousers tucked into his muddy
boots grant often dressed like this he
was kind of a slob they showed one
another a deep and respectful courtesy
and grant generously allowed Lee's
officers to keep their sidearms and the
men to keep their horses and take them
home for the spring planting none would
be arrested or charged with treason four
days later when Lee's army of 28,000 men
marched in to surrender their arms and
colors general joshua l chamberlain of
maine a hero of gettysburg was present
at the ceremony he later wrote of his
observations that day reflecting on his
soldierly respect for the men before him
each passing by and stacking his arms
men who only days before had been his
mortal foes and I quote from Chamberlain
before us in proud humiliation stood the
embodiment of manhood men whom neither
toils and sufferings nor the fact of
death nor disaster nor hopelessness
could bend from their resolve standing
before us now thin worn and famished but
he wrecked with eyes looking level into
ours
waking memories that bound us together
as no other bond
was not such manhood to be welcomed back
into a union so tested and assured on
our part
not a sound of trumpet more nor roll of
drum nor cheer nor word nor whisper of
vain glorying nor motion of man standing
again at the order but an odd stillness
rather and breath holding as if it were
the passing of the dead now this is me
such deep sympathies in a victory so
heavily tinged with sadness and grief
and death this war was and remains to
this day America's bloodiest conflict
having generated a million and a half
casualties on the two sides combined and
then I go on to talk about all of that
for decades to come in every village in
town and the land one could see men
bearing the scars and mutilations of
lost limbs a lingering reminder of the
price they and others had paid so I
guess I kind of think that if if
Chamberlain's troops could find it in
their heart to be that forgiving that
generous we certainly ought to be
towards people in the far distant past
Lincoln
I'll just tack on something Lincoln said
on the last day before the day of his
assassination April 11th
he had a cabinet meeting that morning
and he said these words I hope there
will be no persecution no bloody work
after the war's over enough lives have
been sacrificed too much it's extinguish
our resentment if we expect harmony and
union there has been too much of a
desire on the part of some of our very
good friends to be masters to interfere
with and dictate to those states to
treat the people not as fellow citizens
there's too little respect for their
rights
I do not sympathise in those feelings
close quote
of course if he had known that John
Wilkes Booth was going to hammer him
that night he might have had a different
but and of course that event changed the
complexion of everything but it is
interesting to see to look back on these
these characters in the past and look
back on the the responses they had at
the time something that you may pick up
from these examples is I do use a lot of
oratory I do careful analysis of
important speeches some that are
familiar to you like Lincoln's speeches
Washington's farewell address but some
that are probably not Calvin Coolidge is
a wonderful speech on the 150th
anniversary of the the Declaration of
Independence it's a fantastic speech you
know if you if you want me to I'll read
it to you but I think I've read enough
and of course the John Quincy Adams is
similarly great speech about American
foreign policy all these are things I
give a lot of attention to uh so I do
point back in the direction of primary
sources but I excerpt the the parts that
I think are going to be a particular
interest and and hoped to guide the
reader back towards looking at the whole
thing so I don't know that I have a lot
more to say at this point but I would
love to have your questions so why don't
I stop there
and
well this gentleman had his hand up
almost before my last words around
please wait for the mic in the beginning
of your talk I think you identified a
problem which I see which is in the
academic world soon to be if it isn't
digitized it doesn't exist yes no one is
going to be back in the stacks of the
college library looking for original
work there only being at Google or
somewhere else looking at things that
happen to have been digitized your
comment please oh yeah no I think that's
that's true it's very hard
I'm looking this direction away from my
students here it's very hard to get
people in college writing research
papers to actually go to the library
although actually it's not true any of
you but but but it is generally true I
mean there there's a sort of sense that
if it's not available on the web then I
don't really need to bother with it of
course you can one wonderful thing is
that that you can access very easily now
scholarly articles from some of the most
obscure journals that you would formerly
have to trudge down to the reading room
and or maybe go down in the basement and
find the the 1988 edition of church
history and flip through and find find
something then Xerox it and take it home
with you that was my graduate experience
I can't imagine how much time I wasted
doing that sort of thing when now you
can just Bing Bing Bing and have it so
that that's wonderful in a way but you
know Chesterton somewhere has a saying
that the effect that the problem with
modern travel is it makes it easier and
easier to go to places less and less
worth going to and I think that's a
principle that that that applies or
generally in some ways you know you you
you you you're going to have to do the
work of discernment and just sort of
sheer labor - at some point I look I I
agree with you though there's sin and
this is part of what I was getting
the beginning is this digitisation it's
a it's a mixed bag and and you know
there is this sort of revenge of the
analog concept out there and i i i i
don't really think there's a substitute
for books and even ebooks you know I
have to admit I dislike Kindle I've
tried to use and I don't like it but so
I may have a prejudice there but but it
there's something important that's lost
when the the the author and publisher
are not committed to the idea that the
text is going to be permanent and
character you know come what may you
know it may be overtaken so be it but
and it feels like a way you have another
sort of like cellular biology where you
have lots and lots of discoveries going
on all the time I can see the merit of
having an online kind of reference
source there American history is not
really changing in its broad outlines
from day to day it shouldn't be so I
think I think that the notion of being
committed in history and then literature
to some kind of notion of the integrity
of the word and the weight of the word
you know the the difference between the
experience of writing something at a
typewriter which you're you're young
enough to remember that right and and
sitting in the word process it's a very
different thing well when I was just
signing some books and I and I I get
very nervous because I can't erase
things after I if I misspell somebody's
name
you know I pretty much have to use a
different book it's the same way with
typing you know if you if you get
something wrong I mean you can get out
the correct type and all that junk but
it's a mess
whereas with word processors everything
disappears and and it's in a way you're
less careful about getting it right the
first time because you know it doesn't
really matter
if you get it right the first time and
you may have you know mister you know
Google or Bill Gates or some Specter
hovering over you changing your your
words with audit autocorrect but and so
so you don't even need to take pay
attention to spelling no this is not
good this do we pay a price for that
though that convenience we yes sir yeah
you I noticed you're a graduate of st.
John's College known for their great
books yes which great books influenced
you or most memorable and why Wow and
also should that structure of learning
be adapted more by other colleges and
universities that's a great question
because I actually think I love st.
John's and I both my kids went there and
I served on the board there but I also
think there there are history for one
thing is almost non-existent in the
curriculum at st. John's and so for me
to go into history with a you know kind
of a radical like a conversion
experience coming out of st. John so I
said I still respect what they do but it
there's something lost when you don't
read books in the historical context
I'll give you an example my favorite
example is that I I I had no idea until
I graduated from st. John's and started
studying history a little bit that
Thomas Hobbes wrote Leviathan in the
middle of a civil war you know you would
think that would somebody who insisted
on this kind of totalitarian sovereignty
if I may put it that way
he didn't just pull these ideas out of
the blue he was responding the
circumstances the exigent circumstances
and and and I didn't get that at all and
I just read the vaya --then so I I
wouldn't want to see it universally
adopted I also would like to see it be
continued to be what it is I learned how
to read carefully to read
mostly from st. John's in a way I can't
imagine having learned anywhere else so
I kind of I'm it's like the Athens and
Jerusalem problem I sort of try to hold
to both of these ideals at once the st.
John's close reading text textualism but
also the contextualism of history as a
as a discipline as a great interesting
question and I think I think it would be
good to for other schools to imitate the
st. John you know we have a course and
oh you that is a sort of st. John's e
course but it also has lectures and the
lecturers why I'm one of them and their
two colleagues that help me with it or I
help them I thought sure it's but the
the course was my idea but they give a
lot of historical background a
biographical background you know I
didn't answer you the first part of your
question which which of the great books
affected me the most
I mean Plato Plato and Aristotle the
Bible but particularly the Kierkegaard
fear and trembling after I read fear and
trembling that changed my whole view of
at least at the Torah and Don Quixote
loved Don Quixote Dostoevsky
Oh everything by Dostoevsky I didn't
like can't very much
still dogs and Hegel so I could I loved
some of the readings we did in science
we read Newton's Principia which is
actually quite interesting how we read
Euclid we worked through we worked
through all but twelve books is it of
Euclid 1213 books
yeah and the math tutorial the best
thing I did at Saint John so it was
learning Greek and I think that I
recommend that to everyone of you all
you young people if you haven't start
buttons okay but Greek is better we have
any other yeah you yes yes here you and
the bet you in the back okay thank you
very much for presenting your
interesting book and as you be being an
expert of the narrative of year of the
American nation I want to ask you a
question now because in the current
politics there's this narrative that the
America steers now back to what's this
great times and the great value is
there's the slogan of the current
administration that we all know make it
go back to this great times and now
since since you really typed dive deep
into what what these great times and
shrine
what would your evaluation be does
America go back to those great times or
somewhere else and this attractive labor
has put on something which which is
something I would it be different well I
I see it's a great story I don't I don't
think of a position on the is America
great was it was it ever great you know
you know that that's really and I don't
mean that to be as I do think there's a
there's there are moments of greatness
in American history the moments of shame
in American history but I think the
story as a whole of this this nation
that that sort of starts
and I didn't yeah it it's it starts life
in this in this faraway place at me and
said it's a European it's a province of
Europe in which certain elements of
European civilization are allowed to
flourish in a way that they never could
on native ground so to speak and and I
think the way the way that all of that
that occurs that way it unfolds it's a
magnificent story and it's not a story
that's over yet so
[Applause]
thank thank you very much well uh as you
were speaking one thing I reminded me of
that was thinking about as you're making
your presentation is that for those of
you and my students here that know me
you know how we teach we'd like to talk
about prudence which is the central
virtue of the cardinal virtue and the
central virtue of human activity in many
ways it's citrus the first aspect the
the first element of prudence is the
requirement for memory and you must have
a true memory of the true past in order
to not decide how to proceed so thank
you for that
[Applause]